drifting shoveling it off to Nan Hopkins chipped
over to buar tricyle his next power play goal
will set a team record slap pass over to Newan
Hopkins side of the net what time of score and
there it is Leon trial has become the Edmonton
Oilers franchise alltime leader in Power Play
Goals 127 breaking a tie with Ryan Smith and
Glenn Anderson in and it's one nothing at yeah
you knew it was only a matter of time here's
the first chance here as he flares out into
that typical spot watch Soros here he knows it's
coming great read by him to get over and snuff
that one out but good movement here on this power
play by the oers as they often do they'll morph
into something else little give and go down low
beautiful pass from Newen Hopkins to highman One
Touch to dry Sidle and he elevates up over top of
the glove hand side for a one- nothing lead right
there a little bit of a knuckler as he swings
through that with the big pattle but it was
the movement on the power play that finds that
second opportunity and a goal to go ahead one-
nothing in this game there were two chances there
slim and none Soros wasn't getting that one with
that first goal a power play tally by Leon dle
Save On Foods has given away their first prize
hman and Newen Hopkins will collect the assists
the time 811 and Edmonton is taking the lead